monsieur Ploquin est-ce que vous êtes
connecté que oui mais comme ça faisait
déjà 20 minutes que je l'étais j'ai et
du coup j'ai accepté les appels entrant
c'est pour ça que ça a d sauter pas de
souci bon bonjour à tous bonjour à ceux
d'entre vous qui qui êtes avec nous au
Sénat bonjour à Messieurs Ploquin et
Pujol qui sont en visionférence je vais
commencer pour entamer cette audition de
notre commission d'enquête sur trafic
par vous euh soumettre à une obligation
euh légale qui est que euh un faut
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête et passible des peines prévu
aux articles
434-13 434-14 et 434-15 du code pénal et
donc je vais vous inviter chacun d'entre
vous à prêter serement de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité à lever la
main droite et à dire je le
jure je le
jure merci je jure merci beaucoup
monsieur pourquoi je dirait pourquoi on
vous monre non mais c'est ça ne vaut pas
que pour vous c'est pour tout le monde
merci
beaucoup merci de
votre participation à ces à cette
audition ce que je vous propose c'est
que sur la base d'un questionnaire que
vous avez duû recevoir euh on est un
échange peut-être au cours duquel vous
commencez par une petite oppo liiminaire
sur les éléments saillants que vous
souhaitez porter à notre connaissance et
puis après on se prêtera au jeu des
enfin vous vous si vous l'acceptez au
jeu des questions-réponses je vous
laisse entamer alors je crois que
Monsieur plequin doit nous abandonner
vers 18h20 est-ce que vous souhaitez
commencer non mais je laisse mon
confrère commencer il y a pas de
problème simplement le oui ça nous
laisse quand même une heure on a quand
même une heure devant nous ça va oui
mais vous êtes quatre et on va vous
demander plein de choses on est quatre
ou là d'accord ok d'accord d'accord
alors il faut il faut commencer en en se
présentant c'est cela oui que s'il vous
plaît oui ok d'accord et c'est dommage
qu'on ait pas de retour moi je vois pas
à qui je parle mais bon c'est pas grave
je vous vois pas je vois pas je vois
personne c'est quand même c'est quand
même plus sympa quand on voit les gens
mais il y a pas de retour image ben nous
on vous voit tous c'est de votre côté
peut-être que vous n'avez
pas non c'est pas grave c'est pas
grave P on vous voit pas non plus hein
d'ailleurs qui ah bon vous me voyez pas
non plus non mais on voit l'autre alors
comment je vais faire appareil photo
caméra moyen ben non mais moi j'ai j'ai
tout j'ai mis tout j'ai moi je me vois
moi c'est un peu désagréable quand mais
je vous vois pas vous comment on fait si
vous souhaitez on commence par Monsieur
Pujol et puis on vous prend après on
vous laisse régler problème technique
monsieur
pu bonjour Alors moi je m'appelle
Philippe je suis aujourd'hui écrivain et
réalisateur de documenta je suis
journaliste non pas par mon statut mais
par mon prix alberland que j'ai eu en
2014 sur justement la thématique des
trafics de drogues ça s'appelait
quartier cheat et ça faisait suite à une
autre série que j'avais fait sur
Marseille en 2012 qui s'appelait les
French decnection alors ça s'appelait
French de connection c'est important
parce que pour moi c'est l'inverse de la
French Connection je vais y venir c'est
comment on est passé de la drogue
fabriquée à Marseille à l'époque de de
la French Connection pour être exporté
aux États-Unis avec dans les rues de New
York tous les phénomènes dans les années
60 et 70 que l'on voit aujourd'hui dans
les rues de Marseille de Paris dans les
banlieux strasbourgeoisees toulousaines
et compagnie euh c'est pour moi il y a
eu un renversement une évolution qui
s'est faite qui était je dirais pas
prévisible c'est toujours facile après
coup de dire que cétait prévisible mais
en tout cas qui était logique et donc il
y a eu une évolution ce renversement qui
qui s'est fait je vais pas aller
longemps là-dessus sur sur le Schengen
qui fait que d'un seul coup la drogue a
pu être euh
exporter enfin importer plutôt depuis
par exemple le Maroc pour le cannabis et
le Mexique ou ou la Colombie pour pour
la cocaïne et donc Marseille parce que
c'est un port parce que c'est un une un
lieu d'échange depuis longtemps depuis
plusieurs milliers d'années et bien ça
s'est ça ça s'est retrouvé porte
d'entrée et il y a tous les symptômes à
Marseille pour que la la les trafic de
drogue s'installent de la pop isation
une ville qui a un fonctionnement très
urbain en son centre et très rural dans
ses alentours des banlieux qui sont dans
la ville donc un amoncellement de
villages des banlieux dans la ville et
une grosse paupérisation qui qui est
constante qui qui s'accélère ça ça
fournit la la matière première mais
surtout ce qui est important pour pour
pour comprendre le présent c'est de
savoir ce qui s'est passé on dit tout le
temps aujourd'hui on répète que les les
règlements de
compte sont sont faits par des gens
perpétrés par des gens plus plus jeune
et les victimes sont aussi des gens plus
jeunes mais plus jeunes que quand c'est
c'est c'est ça qu'il faut dire plus
jeune que quand plus jeune qu'avant 2010
en fait depuis 2010 on a des règlements
de compte de jeunes envers d'autres
jeunes je vais venir pourquoi de
maintenant mais il faut comprendre que
jusqu'à à peu près 2010 2008 9 10 ça
s'est mis en place sur 3 4 ans on avait
un banditisme dit traditionnel je n'aime
pas ce ce sens là où il y en a qui
disent grand banditisme j'aime pas non
plus ce sens là on avait un banditisme
qui qui s'entretuait et donc on on avait
au tapis des gens qui avaient 40 ans 35
ans 50 ans Roland Gabel il avait 60 ans
passés Rachid thier il avait 60 ans
passés et à partir de 2010 il y a eu ce
changement c'est là qu'il faut
comprendre une chose qui est importante
2006 il y a la mort d'un cahid assez
important Farid berama Farid berama
faisait le lien entre le banditisme de
la French collection c'est un type qui a
été formé par Tony langi Antoine cossu
donc un homme du Belge donc il a il est
tombé dans le réseau topas le réseau
océan ce qui faisait de l'héroïne donc
il est tombé dans un dans dans un
quelque chose je dirais à l'ancienne
pour parlerit comme comme les mecs des
quartiers et il a quand même fait le le
lien avec le le banditisme actuel c'est
lui qui met en place le les sur
plusieurs cités une sorte d'hégémonie
sur les cités et on regardera qu'en 2000
et 2001 il y a eu un seul règlement de
compte en 2 ans alors les règlements de
compte ne sont les l'indicateur que
d'une chose la concurrence c'est pas
l'indicateur d'un niveau de band ça n'a
aucun aucun rapport il peut avoir 100
morts 50 morts 20 morts ça n'est
l'indicateur que d'une chose de la
concurrence rien d'autre il y a pas
d'autres éléments qui rentre en compte
dans les règlements de compte donc à
partir de
2006 Farid berama est tué par des Corses
sur une affaire de machine à sous et là
c'est 10 12 lieutenants qu'ont
s'entretuer jusqu'en 2010 et ils vont se
rendre compte qu'en fait c'est compliqué
de tenir les cités c'est-à-dire d'avoir
une gestion pyramidale être avoir un
chef et tout une hiérarchie en dessous
toute une série de personnes qui qui va
jusqu'au gur jusqu'aux petites mains qui
va gérer une cité c'est là qui se
rendent compte que il faut il faut voir
les choses autrement et ils prennent
finalement le pli de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans l'économie légale ils
vont ubériser le trafic de su ça va se
faire sur 5 6 ans ça va pas se faire
d'un coup ça démarre doucement en 2010
ça se met vraiment en place en 2016 et
ça s'est accéléré en 2019 avec le le
confinement c'est très simple on a des
grossistes qui sont du trafic
international qui sont des héritiers de
la frenche ou des héritiers de grand
banditisme à travers l'Europe hein ou à
travers le monde qui vont être importé
sur la France et sur l'Europe mais nous
ce qui nous intéresse sur la France des
immenses quantités de drogue
principalement par conttainur assez peu
par GoFast GoFast c'est pour amuser la
télé hein mais en fait il y en a très
peu par rapport aux quantités astronomi
arrient tout simplement dans les
containeurs et généralement c'est tout
simple à Marseille c'est un exemple
c'est pas uniquement Marseille à poruron
arrive par jour 300 50 conteneurs de
charbon de bois depuis l'Afrique de
l'Ouest en Afrique de l'Ouest on a une
mafia Corse implantée puissante et qui
entre autres activités fait aussi dans
la drogue et qui va récupérer par
exemple de la cocaïne et va l'importer
via le Gabon par exemple ça peut être
l'Angola pour d'autres mafias jusqu'à
Marseille ou d'autres villes comme comme
tous les ports en gros tous les ports
d'Europe mais Marseille c'est ce qui ce
qui moi me me concerne et euh cette
drogue là est vendue à des donc ça c'est
les grossistes il vont être vendu à des
semi-grossistes donc ce qu'on appelle
souvent les dealers les chefs de réseau
ils sont chefs de rien du tout ils sont
uniquement semirossist ils ont quelques
hommes avec eux ils récupèrent ce ce
cette tonne là par exemple ils vont la
distribuer sur des cités donc ça se fait
ça se déroule souvent dans des dans des
petites villes autour de Marseille donc
grognac Gignac vitrol les zones
gendarmerie puisquil y a encore des
problèmes entre la relation gendarme
police même si ça améli ioré ça reste
quand même imparfait donc eu ils vont
dans toutes les failles qui peuvent
repérer et bon je vais pas rentrer dans
les détails on aurait pas le temps mais
la drogue ensuite est distribuée sur
certaines grosses cités à Marseille les
plus connu mais c'est pas les seules ça
va être la Castellane ça va être
herbelle ça va être la buusterine ça va
être campagne l'évêque actuellement il y
a la paternelle et voilà et puis alle
tout cassé 10 cités je suis pas sûr même
qu'elles y soi et ces cités là après
avoir desont vont faire à la fois des
ventes au détail et en même temps se
mrossiste pour les autres et à chaque
fois il y a pas de relation de
hiérarchie c'est de l'indépendance
pourquoi ils font ça parce que la
gestion de terrain payer des gens sur le
terrain c'est quelque chose de compliqué
qui prend du temps il y a beaucoup de
traison ça coûte beaucoup d'argent et si
on paye bien les gens parce qu' il y a
quelque chose de complètement faux qui
se répète tout le temps c'est que les
jeunes seraient bien payés je peux vous
assurer c'est totalement farfelu si on
paye bien les les les jeunes ben ils
deviennent les concurrent donc c'est un
souci en fait ils font tout au contraire
et c'est le principal message que je
veux faire passer ce soir que ce qui
tient un réseau de stup aujourd'hui
c'est la dette le but principal et quasi
unique est d'endetter les jeunes qui
vont être les petites mains et donc il y
a plein de méthodes d'endettement la
plus facile et basique c'est d'inventer
un trou dans la caisse l'autre méthode
est toute bête c'est qu'à chaque fois
qu'une patrouille de police rentre dans
une cité et il y a tous remu ménage qui
a une saisie qui a une interpelle tion
même qu' a rien ils vont trouver ce
prétexte pour trouver des coupables des
responsables et leur dire aujourd'hui on
vous paye pas et demain non plus pendant
une semaine on vous pe pas il crée comme
ça des dettes il a plein d'autres
méthodes j'ai ces deux là il crée des
dettes ce qui fait que depuis 2 3 ans il
n'arrive plus trop à recruter les les
les les dans les réseaux maintenant on a
compris quand même dans la jeunesse que
il il y a peu de carrière à faire donc
on se retrouve avec un phénomène qui est
très important et qui explique les
règlements de compte actuels on va voir
tous les vulnérables qui vont rentrer
dans les réseaux de de suéfiant les
vulnérabl c'est avant tout les jeunes de
cité de la de de Marseille qui vont être
avec une MRE seule qui vont être d'une
grande fraterie il vont être le 7è
enfant d'une grande fraterie il va y
avoir ceux qui ont des problèmes psy un
petit peu ceux qu' ont des problèmes
carrément cognitifs qui sont un peu un
peu atteints hein qui comprennent pas
tout il va y avoir quelques handicapés
il va y avoir toute une série de
personnes vulnérables plein de raisons
qui vont être enlevé pour moi c'est
forme d'esclavage qui vont être pris et
et on va les faire daler pendant
quelques jours quelques semaines parfois
quelques mois sans qu'il voit la famille
sans qu'il voit le le reste du monde euh
et après on va les relâcher puis on va
les reprendre et cetera il y a un autre
une autre portion importante de dealer à
Marseille moi je les appelle pas trop
deer c'est les petites mains c'est
j'appelle ça les mains noires et euh qui
vont être des des jeunes des quartiers
populaires de de souvent échapper de
foyer à travers la France qui voit à
Marseille comme l'eldorado comme ça
c'est les médias c'est ce que j'ai pu
faire moi c'est ce qu'on écrit nous
c'est ce qu'on ce qu'on véhicule à la
télé dans nos articles c'est comme ça et
on véhicule peut-être de temps en temps
on y prend pas garde un peu un fantasme
de de l'argent facile à Marseille c'est
tout sauf réaliste si tu es pas un très
gros bandit c'est mort et il y a cette
envie de venir à à Marseille pour
réussir et donc on a énormément de cas
de jeunes de foyer qui viennent à
Marseille et ceux-là ils sont totalement
exploités parce qu'ils n'ont pas de
d'éducateurs de parents de Tonton de de
même de policiers qui connaissent qui
vont les aider les sortir les ils ont
plus ça ils sont totalement séquestré
actuellement j'écris un livre sur ça
donc c'est vraiment un sujet que que je
traite totalement et et enfin il reste
une petite portion alors des fois on en
fait beaucoup dessus mais ça existe
quand même un peu c'est les les micrans
puisque c'est des vulnérables donc ils
font un truc tout simple ils vont à la
plateforme du bâtiment et là où il y a
des BLS qui attendent pour faire du pour
faire du du placau ben il leur disent
bien il y a moyen de faire quelque chose
de faire des sous et ils vont les
exploiter ils vont les ils vont les et
il y a eu plusieurs règlements de compte
cette année de de jeunes africains qui
se sont fait descendre pars ont piqué
dans la caisse en pensant que ça allait
être facile et donc voilà et ce qui va
expliquer après qui est cet étalement de
de de réseau cette auto-entreprise des
réseaux c'est quand on est très endetté
il y a plusieurs possibilités la
première c'est tuer l'adversaire celui à
qui on doit bon c'est pas si simple ils
le font pas si facilement mais ça arrive
la deuxième c'est plutôt celle-là qu'on
fait souvent c'est on s'en dette encore
plus en achetant un ou 2 kg de de cheit
ou de coque et on essaie de le vendre
pour se refaire le problème c'est qu'on
s'en dette plus et pour se refaire il
faut vendre la drogue à un endroit où
elle est achetée et pour ça des coins il
y en a pas des milliers et ils sont
souvent déjà pris et c'est là qu'il y a
des conflits de territoire parce qu' il
faut se refaire faut faire des sous et
et donc la difficulté est là bon je vais
faire court je m'arrête là par ça peut
être très long ce que je veux dire c'est
que le vulnérable en bout de chaîne et
la cible c'est de la cher canon ils sont
très peu payés voire pas du tout voir
exploités il y a des affaires très
sordides il y a de la torture il y a on
les brûle au cigarettes on leur fait on
fait vraiment des ça c'est ça le truc
et je pense que une des des des des
méthodes qu'on devrait mettre en place
c'est de lutter contre avant tout avant
de lutter contre le trafic mais pour les
vulnérables il faudrait vraiment
travailler sur les vulnérables les
profils j'ai donner rapidement quelques
profils il faudrait partir plus en
détail en travaillant sur les
vulnérables on va leur couper un peu les
vibres de de de de de matière de parce
qu'en fait les jeunes de cité veulent de
moins en moins travailler dans les
réseaux hein c'est c'est vraiment de
plus en plus dur pour eux à recruter on
le voit sur les snapchat où ils
embauchent ils demandent ils demandent à
ce qu'il y ait des des des gars qui
viennent sur T cité il font semblant
d'augmenter les tarifs enfin on sent
bien que il y a une galère he à recruter
donc faudrait travailler là-dessus et
ensuite on y viendra certainement sur
les questions de légalisation moi je
suis pas pour une légalisation immédiate
et et et totale je pense qu'il y a plus
subtile à faire je pense qu'il faut
faire un gros travail sur les
consommateurs ets je m'arrête là les
consommateurs sont principalement moi
j'appelle ça des toxicomanes mais je
veux dire des gens sous addictologie
donc on peut taper le consommateur à la
sortie des points de stupe on peut les
condamner tant qu'on veut mais il y a
deux types de consommation en France la
première c'est pour la performance la
performance au travail la performance
dans les études c'est la cocaïne et je
vais donner un exemple cité bassin c'est
une cité en plein dans une zone zone
industrielle de Marseille en ple
centrreville he en plein quartier nord
et elle c'est une cité qui c'est un
drive quiappelle ça un drive donc on
vend on vend de la voiture et elle ouvre
à 6h du matin cette cité parce que tous
les gens du BTP qui doivent tenir avant
ils prenaient un petit jaune ou un petit
rouge pour tenir maintenant ils prennent
des railes de coque parce que les prix
sont devenus accessibles c'est une coque
très mauvaise et je les vois je les ai
vu moi aller à bassins acheter donc il y
a il y a la performance on a des
étudiants on a des gens qui travaillent
dans l'immobilier on a des gens qui
travaillent dans tous les métiers un peu
compliqué dans restauration énormément
et après on a l'antidépresseur qui sont
les stupéfiants les premiers
consommateurs des stupes sont les gens
des quartiers Nord mais de façon
flagrante et et lourde si on
décriminalise à la façon portugaise et
que on rend légale la consommation on va
être dans un cadre légal pour faire un
traitement de santé publique sur ces
populations au Portugal ça a fait
baisser de façon considérable la
consommation je dis pas qu'on y
arriverait d'un seul coup comme ça je
suis pas un spécialiste en France mais
je pense que c'est une voix é un peu
urgente puis c'est de la santé publique
voilà j'auris encore évidemment plein de
trucs à dire mais je voudrais laisser la
parole aux autres merci beaucoup c'était
intéressant il vous avez fait des des
propositions sur lesquelles on pour
rebondir peut-être monsieur Ploquin si
vous avez régler vos problèmes de caméra
ah nous vous voyons et vous nous voyez
formidable je vous cède la parole bon
ben écoutez moi aussi je suis
journaliste et documentariste ça fait 40
ans on va dire que je travaille sur ces
sur ces sujets sur le sujet de la drogue
et donc je fais à la fois des des livres
quoi le dernier gros travail que que
j'ai fait ça s'appelle c'est un Liv qui
s'appelle les narcos français brise
lomerta où je donne la parole aussi bien
au douaniers au policiers que aux
trafiquants de stupéfiants eux-mêmes qui
racontent un peu qu'il font un espèce
d'état des lieux mais comme mon mon
collègue vient déjà de vous raconter un
certain nombre de choses qui se passent
notamment dans dans cette ville de
Marseille qui est un peu la matrice qui
est un peu le chaudron qui est un peu
pour moi le lieu le laboratoire on va
dire à la fois du grand banditisme
français et surtout du trafic de
stupéfiants depuis la la French
Connection en gros où tout s'est inventé
là-bas le le rapport on va dire la cette
économie mondialisée la mondialisation
du trafic de stupéfiant a probablement
été inventé par des corsaux Marseillais
à partir de cette ville d'ailleurs il
travaillait déjà avec des des dockerss
du port de Marseille mais là là on
remonte très loin et euh à partir de là
bon ça ça je crois que vous avez un peu
compris donc comme on a pas beaucoup de
temps je vais essayer de vous amener
tout de suite euh vers ce qui moi me
semble le plus intéressant aujourd'hui
en terme de de nouveauté sur ce marché
des stupéfiant et moi ce qui m'a frappé
la raison pour laquelle j'ai j'ai fait
donc pour pour France 5 pour France
Télévision ce documentaire qui s'appelle
la drogue et dans le prê c'est que
précisément pour moi depuis on va dire
une dizaine d'années ce que je voyais de
nouveau c'est c'est c'est se passait non
plus dans les cités où le mon collègue
vient de le décrire ou o le où le le
trafic est à proprement parl notamment
dans la région parisienne encore plus
mais enquisté c'est qu'il est là depuis
ça fait 4 C générations que les que les
trafiquants se succèdent et se et se
remplacent et sont toujours de plus en
plus dures parce qu'il faut toujours en
faire plus que la génération précédente
donc je voulais aller au-delà de cela et
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est de commencer
à rencontrer des gens
notamment en S sa qui est probablement
le 93 qui est probablement on va dire
qui est qualifié par par certains
policiers de de narcodépartement parce
qu'en fait les liquidités qui circulent
sont probablement beaucoup plus
importante que partout ailleurs en
France et que cette économie parallèle
qui n'est pas seulement alimentée par
les stupéfiants à déborder l'économie
réelle et probablement la supplanter on
voir si les je si les Jeux Olympiques
parviennent à inverser la tendance mais
j'en suis pas sûr mais en gros je suis
parti de là et du de rencontres que je
faisais dans ce département de jeunes
qui commençaient à me dire mais
maintenan tu sais ici euh nous on est un
peu àé trroit ça commence à être dur
puis tu vois on s'entretue parce qu'on
s'entretue aussi je voudrais le dire
ailleurs qu'à Marseille mais ça se dit
beaucoup moins et moi je suis assez
frappé d'ailleurs à chaque fois qu'il y
a un mort à Marseille on est appelé à
s'exprimer à la télévision et à côté de
ça moi à chaque fois je dis mais
attendez il y a eu un mort hier à côté
de Paris là dit kilomè de de la tourfel
pourquoi personne n'en parle donc on en
parle pas mais ça se fait autant donc je
j'ai été frappé de rencontrer des jeunes
qui me disaient bon c'est saturé on on
risque de se faire tuer on a pas de
place on a pas d'espace et ils ont
commencé à les prospecter on va dire
dans des villes secondaires et à
s'éloigner des régions de la région
parisienne en l'occurrence et pour moi
le grand phénomène de ces 10 dernières
années c'est la pénétration de la drogue
euh dans les territoires on va dire
d'abord les les les villes moyennes
secondaires et ensuite les les
territoires ruraux le constat que je
fais aujourd'hui c'est que cette drogue
n'est plus l'apanage comme elle l'était
dans les années 80 90 on va dire de
consommateurs
ultraurbain
Marseille Lyon Paris la région lilloise
mais que
maintenant vous seriez surpris mais bon
moi quand j'ai commencé cette enquête
donc j'ai suivi ces jeunes je dis mais
tu vas où tu vas tu vas t'installer où
j'en ai suivi un comme ça qui m'a amené
vers vers alançon Lemand et en fait j'ai
compris à ce moment-là si vous voulez
que c'est toujours pareil le le le
trafic de stupéfiant c'est c'est qu'
énergie formidable parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'argent et qui qui se
réinvente en permanence qui réinventent
des méthodes en permanence nouvelles et
là bah ils sont tout simplement partis
euh à la conquête de territoir qu'ils
estimaiit vierge et qu'il était parce
qu'on trouvait pas si facilement de la
drogue il y a 20 ans à alançon
qu'aujourd'hui et en fait ils ont ils
ont créé ils ont étendu ce marché dans
dans ces villes là et et donc je je me
suis retrouvé comme ça dans des villes à
priori rurales qui étaient jusqu'à
présent relativement paisible euh où euh
bah écoutez il commençait à y avoir des
règlements de compte alors les
règlements de compte à Marseille c'est
une chose mais dans ces endroits-là dès
lors que vous avez des règlements de
compte dans des villes comme châteurou
euh Blois Cavaillon enfin des villes un
peu secondaires comme ça vous pouvez
vous dire que c'est un marqueur le
marqueur d'une véritable implantation
que c'est au départ il y a pas de
règlement de compte et c'est la raison
pour laquelle ils viennent c'està dire
qu'il viennent s'installer là il y a pas
de
concurrence il suffit d'aller chercher
des clients il faut il faut aller
chercher des clients mais ça c'est un
autre problème les clients en vérité
aujourd'hui sont partout et finalement
les campagnes françaises ne sont ne sont
plus des campagnes françaises que nous
avons rêvé les campagnes françaises sont
habitées maintenant par des gens qui
sont souvent des voilà des pér urbains
les anciens urbains donc ça ça a
complètement changé à ce niveau-là et
donc les règlements de compte
surviennent trop tard c'est-à-dire que
le moment où ça se passe ce qui est le
cas aujourd'hui tous ces règlements de
compte dans ces villes secondaires
signifie que bon on il y a quelque chose
qui s'est passé qu'on a pas vu passer
que la police n'a pas vu que et il
profit parce qu'à partir du moment où il
y a règlement de compte c'est qu'il y a
vraiment une bagarre sur le terrain pour
implter pour pour vendre et cetera le
produit et qu' y a pas qu'un seul dealer
mais qu'il y en a plusieurs qui sont pas
d'accord et qui s'entretuent comme
d'habitude donc ça signifie que bah ils
ont ilst ils ont tout compris ils sont
allés vers des villes où la police
judiciaire était très peu présente où la
police urbaine la sécurité publique
était déjà occupé autre chose dans des
villes où les gendarmes ont mis quelques
années maintenant ils se sont convertis
on va dire à cette nouvelle matière mais
la gendarmerie a mis un certain temps je
sais qu'au Sénat on connaît mieux les
par définition les sénateurs connaissent
mieux les les gendarmes que les
policiers mais les les les gendarmes ont
fait un effort colossal là depuisel
quelques années mais ils ont mis du
temps et donc il y avait voilà les
trafiquants de stupéfiants le le le leur
façon d'avancer c'est ça c'est deons
faible ils ont ciblé les villes où
finalement la la gendarmerie était pas
forcément encore formée pour pour
détecter et tout un coup du jour
lendemain on s'aperçoit que dans les
contrôles routiers qu'on fait quand il y
a des problèmes d'excès de vitesse
d'accident de tout ce que vous voulez
bah c'est plus c'est plus du calva qu'on
trouve dans le dans le sang des
conducteurs français c'est de la cocaïne
des amphétamines des produits
stupéfiants en tout genre du cannabis de
la Marana tout ce que vous voulez et
tout d'un coup on en trouve plus même
davantage et dans des département Mo ça
m'a surpris comme l'Orne euh comme voilà
les départements de Normandie tout d'un
coup il s'avérait que lors de ces
problèmes ces contrôles routiers
classiques apparaissait davantage des de
la consommation de stupéfiants que de la
consommation d'alcool ça veut dire que
le produit aujourd'hui est largement
implanté et en gros la question n'est
plus seulement celle de la préfecture de
police de Paris ou de la Préfecture de
Police de de de Marseille mais la
question maintenant se pose dans tout
les recoins du territoire de savoir
comment on traite ça comment on combat
cette consommation comment et et et on
se réveille probablement un peu en
retard c'est pas c'est je trouve ça très
intéressant que vous fassiez cette cette
cette enquête aujourd'hui mais on est on
se réveille un peu tard notamment si
vous penchez par exemple sur la question
de la de ce qui se passe dans le port du
Havre euh moi moi je suis stupéfait
parce que ça fait ça fait environ 10 ans
qu'en gros les trafiquants les
organisations criminelles mondiales
parce que derrière derrière on a quand
même les organisations criminelles ultra
puissantes mondiales qui ont des moyens
absolument colossaux ça fait 10 ans que
ces organisations ont
détecté le maillon faible qui était le
port du abre pourquoi parce qu'on avait
pas une police judiciaire dimensionnée
parce que le port lui-même et les disons
l'activité portuaire avait doublé de
volume ce qui est formidable sur le plan
économique en dis an sauf qu'on avait
oublié que dans ce même temps il
faudrait peut-être multiplier par deux
puisque ça avait doublé en volume le
nombre de douaniers le nombre de
policiers donc on se réveille
aujourd'hui c'est pas trop tard c'est
c'est jamais trop tard je vais pas vous
dire ça parce que faut pas se décourager
mais on se réveille aujourd'hui en gros
la digue à sauté et il faut la
reconstruire c'est un peu un peu ça la
la la grande difficulté mais pour vous
rassurer parce que je vais pas voilà
monopoliser ça fait déjà un petit moment
que je parle je voulais juste terminer
sur enfin je terminer je peux vous en
parler aussi pendant jusqu'à demain
matin si vous voulez mais bon vous avez
autre chose à faire mais c'est juste un
un un truc pour terminer qui que j'ai
retrouvé là en en me penchant sur sur le
fait que j'allais intervenir auprès de
vous donc je suis tombé sur un article
qui date et c'est ça qui est important
du 5 mai
1983 c'est-à-dire il y a 40 ans et c'est
un article c'est une interview que je
que je fais à l'époque dans un quotidien
qui s'appelait qui s'appelait qui
n'existe plus le Matin de Paris et c'est
en fait une interview du patron de la
brigade des stupéfiants de Paris et le
titre c'est je n'ai pas les moyens et je
l'ai relu et c'est absolument
extravagant parce qu'en réalité ce qu'il
il y a François mitteran à l'époque qui
dit bon il faut il faut se fâcher contre
le trafic de stupéfiants François
mitéron fait une conférence de presse
sur la drogue on va se fâcher contre le
trafic de stup moi je vais voir le
patron d'abri d'up qui s'appelait Marcel
Morin qui est un policier qui est un
grand flic qui est mort il y a pas très
longtemps et qui a notamment
cassé à une époque la la French
Connection à à Marseille et là il est en
poste à Paris et il dit mais attendez
moi je veux bien mais il faudrait
peut-être multiplier par 10 le nombre de
policiers de fonctionnaires de police de
la brigette des stupes si vous voulez
que j'y arrive il me dit des choses
comme ça qui sont qui raisonneraient en
réalité ce qui ce qui me frappe moi
c'est qu'on pourrait euh re publier
aujourd'hui l'interview de Marcel Morin
en 1983 et qui pourrait dire à peu près
la même chose ce qui signifie c'est pas
pour vous décourager encore une fois
mais c'est pour vous dire pour essayer
d'inscrire le débat dans dans dans la
dans la profondeur dans le temps c'est
qu'en fait la drogue pour l'instant est
quand même la grande gagnante de la
criminalité organisée et que ça va être
assez compliqué de se fâcher comme
disait François mitteran voilà merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup euh alors pour
une raison technique qui m'échappe on
peut pas faire plus de 4 heures de
d'audition consécutive et donc donc à
18h on va avoir une une rupture de de
faisceau donc je vais proposer à
monessieur molignier Bertrand Monet
d'intervenir ici en salle si par hasard
messieur Pujol et et pleoquin vous avez
envie de sauter sur la chaise parce que
quelque chose vous arrache les oreilles
vous le faites et puis si c'est pas
possible avant 18h de toute façon la
diffusion continue sur le web vous
pouvez écouter et on est preneur de vos
écrits comme il vous a été
demandé ah non on relance la vision on
me dit qu'on relance la visio et vous
pourrez vous reconnecter donc voilà il y
a pas de il y a pas de sujet euh alors
je passe la parole à qui la demande
allez bonjour William Molinier donc
Europe 1 je vais essayer d'être d'être
court moi je je donc je suis journaliste
à Europe 1 et je m'occupe des des sujets
de sécurité intérieure de défense et et
de renseignement alors je n'ai pas comme
mes comme mes confrères je suis pas
aller voir de l'autre côté moi c'estàd
du côté des des trafiquants donc moi ma
connaissance est plutôt euh on va dire
du point de vue policier ou en tout cas
très macro je vais peut-être en profiter
euh je je vais pas redire ce qui a été
dit mais je vais je vais en profiter
peut-être
pour de cette intervention pour pour
vous parler dans dans dans ce propos
liminaire de la façon dont la la presse
quotidienne nationale c'estàdire celle
dans laquelle euh j'exerce depuis depuis
10 ans comment nous on traite de cette
de ce sujet euh de la lutte contre les
les stupéfiants euh quelques remarques
d'abord d'abord un constat alors je
crois que ça ça a été dit devant vous he
ces dernières semaines l'estub c'est la
première matière criminelle au au monde
3 milliards d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires en France 230000 personnes
qui vivent directement ou indirectement
du du trafic de de stupéfiants en France
des délis
Connex dans les quartiers même si
effectivement plus aucun territoire
aujourd'hui n n'est épargné comment nous
donc médias on rend compte de de de
cette quotidien de de ce quotidien
pardon au quotidien de de cette réalité
on met en fait l'accent sur c'estàd
qu'on fait monter le le le sujet des
stupéfiants en tout cas des règlements
de compte liés au aux stupéfiants dans
dans deux cas de figure un c'est quand
il y a une victime collatérale donc une
victime innocente et deux quand les des
mineurs sont
euh sont impliqués eux-mêmes dans le
trafic et qui euh et qui euh s'entretue
euh là vous avez dans ces deux cas de
figure une caisse de de résonance
médiatique nationale vous avez ça sur
toutes les chaînes info dans en une ça
montte voilà en une dans tous les dans
tous les les les titres de presse mais
globalement on chronique assez peu
finalement euh on chronique pas
régulièrement
euh les règlements de compte entre
trafiquants alors qu'en fait les
chiffres ils dev devrait effectivement
nous alerter puisque globalement on vous
les a donné je crois on est à 400
personnes enfin 400 morts lié mort
violente lié au au trafic de stupéfiant
un peu plus ou moins je ne sais plus
mais c'est cet ordre d'idée en 7 ans
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus que le le
terrorisme où on a 270 morts depuis 2012
dont 80 % concentrés sur deux attentats
le 13 novembre et Nice comparaison non
pas évidemment pour dire qu'on surtraite
le terrorisme mais si vous mettez ces
deux euh ces deux données en parallèle
on voit bien qu'on sous-traite
médiatiquement les morts violentes liées
au au trafic de stupéfiants et j'allais
dire le stupéfiant le produit stup enfin
le le le le trafic en lui-même puisque
aujourd'hui une tonne de de de de
cocaïne là où ça faisait peut-être
l'ouverture des journaux il y a 20 ans
aujourd'hui ça ça fait un entrefilet ou
un petit papier pourquoi est-ce qu'on on
sous-traite à mon sens cette question là
d'abord évidemment pour des questions de
de ressources internes à la à la presse
quotidienne nationale c'est une matière
très compliquée envoyer un journaliste
ou une équipe de journalistes dans sur
les lieux d'une fusillade dans un
quartier showud surtout en en
télé c'est une prise de risque pour la
sécurité du du du du journaliste parce
que
bah tout simplement parce que comme les
policiers les journalistes ne sont pas
les
bienvenus lorsqu'il y a un fait de ce
type pour s'implanter dans le quartier
ça demande du temps ça demande
l'investissement ça demande un travail
de de de fond important des moyens en
fait on a de ce point de vuelà les mêmes
les mêmes sujets les mêmes
problématiques que que les
enquêteurs autre raison ça a été un peu
abordé mais autre raison pour laquelle
on on soustraite de mon point de vue
cette question là c'est parce que le
trafic de stupéfiants en fait fait
partie du quotidien des Français il
s'est intégré totalement au au paysage
et donc d'une certaine manière on ne le
voit plus et on ne
lerque chronique plus c'est le point de
Deal le le la cage d'escalier squatté
c'est devenu en fait une sorte de
décorum habituel de certains espaces
public et si on dézoome on ne raconte
pas non plus quotidiennement le
blanchiment de trafic de stupéfiants à
travers le bureau de tabac à travers le
fast food l'entreprise de BTP qui vient
faire qui vient faire des travaux à
l'inverse à l'inverse donc ce qu'on va
traiter nous c'est le les nuisances
connexes au au trafic de stupéfiants dès
lors qu'ell deviennent insupportable ou
inacceptaable pour les riverins les
squats les vols les violences et cetera
et cetera et même logique côté
blanchiment c'est vrai que on on on
s'intéresse au montage ultra complexe
qui demande une ingénierie particulière
mais donc la criminalité du quotidien
finalement d'une manière
générale les les médias en tout cas les
médias nationaux euh s'y intéressent peu
au quotidien et c'est justement ça donc
qui est à mon sens inquiétant parce que
ça veut dire que finalement l'opinion
publique c'est en quelque sorte endormi
mis sur sur ce sujet finalement une
transaction de stupéfiant dans la rue
c'est devenu quelque chose de totalement
euh normalisé
euh et que si elle ne provoque pas de
nuisance ou d'incidents cela ne va pas
être dénoncé
euh l'omerta en fait qui s'est installé
dans dans dans ces quartiers c'est
devenu non pas une omerta c'est pas
c'est pas le mot mais en fait c'est
c'est cet
omerta se dilue en fait dans une sorte
de
d'indifférence enfin se prolonge dans
une sorte d'indifférence médiatique
euh juste un exemple aujourd'hui vous un
habitant une personne appelle au
standard d'une radio ou ou ou envoie une
lettre à une une rédaction explique
qu'il y a un trafic de stupéfiant en bas
de chez lui bon courage pour déplacer
une équipe de journalistes sur place
euh voilà il a il aura toutes les les
les difficultés du monde à médiatiser
son affaire parce que euh
malheureusement c'est devenu une une une
banalité
euh donc pour conclure on traite ce
sujet dès lors qu'il est exceptionnel et
en fait c'est là la difficulté
c'est-à-dire que le trafic de de de
stupéfiant puisqu'il est omniprésent
dans la vie des français n'est plus
quelque chose euh
d'exceptionnel et globalement euh les
les les politiques publiques euh tentent
ENF en tout cas c'est comme ça que moi
je le perçois euh au au vu des des des
annonces depuis euh euh de de depuis que
je suis ce ce sujet tente euh d'apporter
des mesures exceptionnel alors que
euh c'est surtout des réponses directes
en fait au trafic de stupéfiants euh
qu'il faudrait euh qu'il faudrait
apporter c'est-à-dire recentrer
peut-être l'action euh sur euh euh le
trafic à proprement parl mais donc on
pourra y revenir sur d'éventuelles
autres
questions merci beaucoup ben écoutez
Bertrand Mony vous allez terminer ce t
de piste bonsoir je suis Bertrand Monet
je suis professeur à ldec où je suis
titulaire de la cher management des
risques criminels et dans le cadre de
mes recherches je publie des reportages
en partenariat avec le le journal Le
Monde donc j'ai fait une série de de
reportages il y a 3 ans un documentaire
télévisé et une série récente de
reportages et de documentaires
spécifiquement axé sur une organisation
criminelle qui s'appelle le cartel de
Sinaloa qui est l'un des grands cartel
mexicain je travaille par ailleurs sur
un cartel enfin une organisation
ncoorganisation colombienne dans la
région de Cali est l'une des l'un des
gros producteurs de de cocaïne notamment
de la cocaïne qui arrive ici et puis je
travaille au Brésil sur deux
organisations toujours de la même façon
en essayant de rencontrer des membres de
ces organisations pour les filmer et
filmer leur trafic je travaille au
Brésil
dans la région de San Paulo sur le
primero commando de la capitale qui est
l'une des des principales mafia
brésiliennees qui est stratégique pour
notre sujet parce que c'est elle qui
tient le port de Santos qui est l'un des
grands ports duquel proviennent les
tonnes de cocaïne qui arrivent en Europe
j'ai été enlevé d'ailleurs par le PCC
cette organisation 28 octobre 2016 et
puis je travaille aujourd'hui sur le
commando vermeillo qui est une autre
mafia brésilienne qui elle aussi est
très active en Europe notamment via le
Portugal mais pas seulement alors moi
j'ai un œil finalement assez non pas
éloigné de la France mais mais je serai
beaucoup moins informant que les les
journalistes que vous avez invité ici
sur le cas français pour autant je pense
que effectivement je je peux peut-être
être utile à votre commission dans la
mesure où euh je peux tout d'abord ce
sera le premier point décrire rapidement
à qui nous faisons face euh en tout cas
pour la cocaïne je parle pas du tout de
cannabis je ne connais pas mais la
cocaïne et les autres drogues qui
arrivent ici bah finalement elles sont
produites par qui l'autre point pour
reprendre celle qui parmi les questions
euh que vous nous avez posé en tout cas
celles sur lesquelles je peux être
intéressant informant
euh quels sont les points qui permettent
enfin quels sont les les les les façons
dont ces organisations proposent
distribuent de nouveaux produits pour
pas être dans la gardeaprès euh trisème
sujet l'utilisation des outils
numériques notamment des cryptoonnaies
qui est un vrai sujet moi dans tous les
échanges que j'ai avec eux les
conversations que j'ai avec ces gens il
me parlent que de ça aujourd'hui euh
autre point qui à mon av est central
notamment dans la fonction de votre
institution euh le blanchiment je pense
qu'aujourd'hui en matière de politique
d'action publique il y a énormément à
faire sur le sujet j'ai bien vu que vous
avez entendu des gens autrement plus
qualifiés que moi pour parler de ce
sujet- là mais l'axe d'effort à mon avis
il est là euh et puis enfin peut-être
d'autres recommandations peut-être des
réflexions sur ces politiques publiques
al les organisations sur lesquelles je
travaille moi je suis professeur àeddec
une école de management donc j'ai un œil
assez microéconomique sur le sujet et
finalement la comparaison avec une
multinationale légale elle répond
malheureusement très très bien ce sont
des organisations agiles Apple
aujourd'hui n'est pas le Apple d' y a 10
ans malheureusement les gens qui
produisent les drogues ont exactement la
même agilité c'est terrible à dire mais
c'est vrai celles sur lesquelles je
travaille sont des organisations qui
sont de deux types les organisations
mafieuses brésiliennes sont extrêmement
structurées le le primé au commando de
la capitale dont je parlais tout à
l'heure c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas été exécuté par
ces gens j'ai été enlevé par un groupe
qui voulait m'exécuter mais il ne
pouvait pas le faire de leur propre chef
il fallait que je sois jugé par un juge
et cetera par l'étatmajor du PCC qui est
en prison bref extrêmement pyramidal et
vous avez d'autres modèles notamment ce
des cartels mexicains notamment le
cartel de Sinaloa qui sont des
fédérations qui sont en fait des
coopérative pour reprendre des modèles
que nous connaissons et ce sont à mon
sens les plus dangereuses parce qu'elles
sont capables de s'adapter de façon
extrêmement rapide au marché qu'elles
souhait pénétrer euh je ne sais pas si
les cartels mexicains sont les
principaux exportateur de la cocaïne qui
est consommée en France mais en tout cas
sont des exportateurs majeurs et le
cartel de Sinaloa il est structuré de la
façon suivante il y a un étatmajor qui
comprend un nombre très restreint de
membres dirigés par El maillot le chef
qui a succédé el chapo enfin bref et en
dessous ce sont des clans autonomes il a
une centaine de clans le cartel de
Sinaloa attention hein c'est 19000
membres les gens qui pour beaucoup sont
à l'origine de ce qui arrive ici encore
une fois c'est vraiment des
multinationales et c'est un exemple hein
19000 membres des dizaines de milliards
de dollars de chiffre d'affaires et
chacun de ces cette grosse centaine de
clans on va parler de Business Unit si
vous m'autorisez cet anglicisme ici est
structuré de façon très autonome il peut
faire ce qu'il veut je lisais récemment
dans le Wall Street Journal que le
trafic de fantanille qui est le
blockbuster du cartel
aujourd'hui était arrêté par le cartel
de Sinaloa c'est impossible à dire parce
que certains clans oui ont décidé
d'arrêter d'autres continuent à produire
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont produire demain
chaque clan a une autonomie totale et
une innovation réelle entre ses mains
pour produire un produit qui tue c'est
c'est la façon dont c'est structuré
pourquoi c'est uniquement dans une
vocation dans un but économique
d'agilité de création de valeur c'est
terrible à dire mais ces gens sont des
extrémistes économiques donc voilà à qui
on a affaire après au sein de chaque
clan voilà y a les sicarios il y a ceux
qui s'occupent de la Supply Chain de la
logistique attention c'est des gens qui
ont des connexions dans le monde entier
moi j'ai des heur de témoignage filmé de
gens qui m'expliquent combien coûte le
le le le l'export d'un kil de cocaïne
alors non pas depuis la Colombie mais
depuis couakan depuis leur territoire
jusqu'ici en m'expliquant que le
principal coût c'est pas le coût de
transport c'est le coût de corruption et
quand on parle de
corruption alors ça je l'avais pas mis à
l'image parce que j'ai pas pu le
vérifier mais c'est en tout cas ce
qu'ils disent il me donneent poste par
poste tous les gens qui le corrompent
les transitaires les dockers oui mais
les douaniers oui mais les policiers et
pas seulement au Mexique et pas
seulement à Rotterdam et pas seulement
enverse et il me disent évidemment si on
pr pas 18000 dollars par kilo 1 kil de
cocaïne c'est à peu près 60 63000 pure
100 % 60 63000 € ici P à 100 % le prix
de vente le prix auquel ils vendent ici
sachant qu'il achète 1000 dollars en
Colombie donc la marge est importante
sur ces 63000 dollars le principal coût
c'est 18000 dollars 15000 € pour la
corruption voilà donc voilà ils sont ils
ont cette capacité hein comme c'était ça
a été dit de façon évidemment très juste
par Monsieur Ploquin ils ils ont cette
capacité encore une fois de pénétration
très forte et très ancienne de leur de
des hubs que sont les pororts donc en
face voilà on a des multinationales qui
vendent des produits qui sont très très
rentables j'étais terrifié là il y a
quelques semaines lors de du dernier
entretien que j'ai eu avec ces gens du
cartel de caloa je leur disais bon alors
qu'est-ce que vous pensez monsieur Pujol
vous vous évoquiez ce sujet de la
légalisation je le pososea la question
parce que finalement leur business
historique c'est la Marie Rana c'est en
train de mourir parce Queaux États-Unis
de plus en plus Mar est légalisé il dit
mais nous on n'est pas inquiet parce que
on est comme des qu
on aura toujours du business pourquoi
parce que ce que nous vendons finalement
c'est la satisfaction de certains vis et
on trouvera toujours des gens qui ont
des vis à satisfaire donc la
légalisation c'est pas le problème on
vendra du cannabis encore plus fort en
THC et cetera et cetera je sais que vous
avez auditionné des gens encore une fois
plus autorisés les produits qui
vendent encore une fois ils sont vendus
avec une marge telle que leur capacité
de pénétration à mon avis est
difficilement
contterable le trafic de cocaïne encore
une fois selon le type de cocaïne dont
on parle et selon les organisations et
le nombre d'intermédiaires qui est
central he dans la structure du prix la
rentabilité du trafic de C varie entre
4000 et 6000 %. il y a pas de produits
légaux qui soit aussi rentable le trafic
de fantanille qui est une drogue qui tue
qui est la principale responsable des
130000 morts par overdose d'opioï aux
États-Unis on n pas trop concerné
aujourd'hui ça risque de venir le trafic
de fanttainille c'est 2400 % et c'est
beaucoup plus simple à produire c'est
une chaîne logistique extrêmement
réduite j'ai pu filmer et toute la
production c'est d'une simplicité
terrible voilà donc des multinationales
qui ont des produits très puissants euh
pour revenir sur le fantanil deème point
de mon propos la façon dont ces
organisations arrivent pour répondre à
cette question que vous posez euh
arrivent à pénétrer ses marché là ça
j'ai pu l'observer j'ai pu observer un
échec il y a 4 ans 3 ans pardon un
produit qui a pas pris ici qui s'appelle
le cristal qui est une métamphétamine
qui marche très bien aux États-Unis qui
marche très bien en Amérique du Sud qui
marche pas ici et j'ai pu euh entendre
des captations de son sur WhatsApp entre
les narcos du cartel de Sinaloa et leurs
principaux clients hein les grossistes
hein qui achètent ici où les gens du
cartel disaient on va te mettre un peu
de Swarovski Swarovski pour eux c'est le
surnom du cristal en référence à la
marque de de de de bijoux swwarovski on
va te mettre un peu de swwarovski
gratuit comme ça tu pourras tester le
marché et en face les gens disaient oui
vas-y vas-y on verra bon forcé de
constater je parle sous l'autorité de
des journalistes qui suivent ces sujetsl
bien mieux que moi ça n'a pas pris ici
al je dis pas qu'il y en a pas c'est
très réduit ce qu'il teste aujourd'hui
c'est ce qu'ils m'ont dit euh c'est la
possibilité de vendre sur les marchés
européens jéalon de la semaine prochaine
la semaine dernière pardon et ça y est
ça a pris euh de vendre du fantanil hein
cet opioïde extrêmement puissant qui est
entre 30 à 40 fois plus fort que
l'héroïne vous avez sans doute vu des
reportages sur ce sujet c'est terrifiant
pour l'instant on est épargné pourquoi
parce qu'aux États-Unis il y avait un
marché préexistant qui était celui de la
consommation euh de de de médicaments
opioïdes de façon totalement abusive qui
était qui étit consommé comme des
drogues qui se marché séant tari sous
l'autorité des des S sous l'impulsion
des autorités sanitaires américaine ça a
créé un vide et donc beaucoup de gens
qui étaient addictes à ces médicaments
se sont tournés vers l'héroïne qui
n'étit pas assez forte et donc vers un
produit encore plus fort le fantanî
produit par les Mexicains au en Europe
on n' pas ça on est préservé de ça mais
pour autant ils peuvent tout à fait
essayer de créer des conditions de
marché encore une fois et ils le font en
proposant du fantanil à leurs
partenaires commerciaux j'en ai
rencontré quelques
ce sont des alors c'est pas des gens qui
appartiennent en tant que tel à des
organisations c'est des gens qui sont
freelance mais qui ortent des tonnes de
drogues qu'il revendent qui ce sont des
intermétiaires entre les Mexicains la
mocro mafia la Camora d'autres
organisations d'Europe de l'Est et ces
gens-là ils achètent par centaines de
millions je reviens à ça ce troisième
point comment se règlent les
transactionsi ma question c'est toujours
comment est-ce que vous faites payer
est-ce qu'on paye avant est-ce qu'on
paye après c'est toujours un sujet parce
qu'ils ne connaissent pas ils sont
obligés de gagner de nouveaux marchés
donc bah des fois ils prennent des
risques financiers très forts et donc
soit ils disent tu tu nous paye d'abord
et on te livre après bon mais ça marche
pas toujours ou alors ils font confiance
et il prennent le risque de ne pas être
payé sachant que eux sont quand même à
des milliers de kilomètres donc c'est
toujours c'était toujours compliqué
aujourd'hui ils ont une solution magique
qui s'appelle le Bitcoin ils se font
payer pour beaucoupin de clan du cartel
non pas par leurs clients américains
mais pour leurs clients par leurs
clients européens c'estd les clients sur
lesquels ils ont prise assez faible en
cas d'impayé ils sont payés en
cryptoonnaie et je ne dis pas que le le
le Bitcoin est un outil inventé pour des
pour le blanchiment d'argent je dis
absolument pas ça la vocation de Bitcoin
elle est magnifique hein mais le
blockchain qui garantit finalement
l'anonymat d'un détenteur de Wallet d'
un portefeuille de Bitcoin c'est
évidemment extrêmement attractif pour
ces gens-là euh ils ont une question
quand même qui est de le blanchiment
après c'est-à-dire que on peut être payé
en Bitcoin mais si on veut utiliser son
argent en monnaie Fiat il va bien
falloir le convertir et à ce momentl
évidemment vous allez attirer
l'attention du banquier mais toujours
est-il que oui pour cet usage du
numérique en tout cas le seul point sur
lequel je je peux je pense pour être
informant c'est effectivement les narcos
en tout cas ceux que je vois y compris
les Brésiliens utilisent massivement les
cryptos dernier point le blanchiment sur
les techniques de blanchiment elles sont
connues je sais que vous avez audité ici
des gens auditionnés ici des gens
autrement plus plus autorisés encore une
fois mais ils blanchissent de façon
classique par injection du cash dans la
trésorerie de commerce avec qui ils ont
des partenariats ou qu'il possède
évidemment en utilisation ça c'est un
vrai sujet dans parmi les professions
assujéties j'ai entendu ici des banques
très trèsè très critiqué sans doute à
raison parfois c'est le tras peut-être
un peu forcé les banques dans certains
pays font face à un tsunami d'argent
sale donc elles font ce qu'elles peuvent
mais elles sont elles se mettent en
conformité évidemment avec les lois et
les les directives mais il y a je pense
un acteur qui est massivement utilisé
que sont les bureaux de change les
bureaux de change et surtout dans le
dans leur vocation de transfert de fonds
de cash vers des comptes en banque son
sont très très utilisés par les narcos
et ça je pense que ils sont assujétis
aux mêmes lois que les banques je doute
de
la vélocité de ces entreprises à mettre
en place ce que les banques ont mis en
place et puis surtout surtout surtout
dans le blanchiment utilisé les les
techniques de blanchiment utilisé par
ces grandes organisations criminelles je
parle pas des autres mais les grandes
organisations criminelles elles doivent
blanchir des dizaines de milliards de
dollars et pour ça il y a pas 50
solutions il faut utiliser des paradis
bancaires c'est-à-dire des États qui euh
sont censés réagir mais ne réagissent
quasiment pas lorsqu'une demande de
coopération judiciaire leur est faite et
ne transmettent aucune information sur
les données bancaires de criminels
recherché par des états-tiers je pense
notamment à Dubaï où j'ai assisté à un
entretien entre un narcotrafiquant du
cartel de Sinaloa et une société
fiduciaire dont des cadres lui expliqué
j'ai enregistré hein cette cet entretien
encore une fois j'en ai fait une partie
d'un documentaire qui est publique sur
le le monde euh et ce que ce que disent
ces cadres de la société fiduciaire est
parfaitement légal ils ne commettent
aucune infraction à Dubaï en expliquant
à un ararco Mexicain dont ils ne
connaissent même pas le nom comment
blanchir via l'immobilier à Dubaï pour
conclure s'il est une action à mon avis
qui doit être conduite en matière
d'action publique
euh certes
elle doit avoir un volet judiciaire mais
aussi diplomatique le plus dynamique
qu'il soit
il n'y aura pas de ralentissement de
business illégaux qui chiffre à 2400 ou
6000 % de marge tant qu'on ne touchera
pas le couteau suisse qui permet à ces
gens de blanchir ces gens vendent de la
drogue non par plaisir mais par à pas du
gain s'il est devenu difficile pour eux
de blanchir c'est-à-dire d'utiliser leur
argent ils seront tentés ils seront
moins tentés de le faire et l'outil qui
leur permet de blanchir ce sont les
paradis bancaires au premier rang
desquels Dubaï je vais pas m'étendre sur
ces raisons mais c'est c'est lié à
l'importance de l'immobilier à Dubaï et
l'action publique à mon avis elle doit
aussi porter sur des pressions sur ces
trous noirs de la finance mondiale les
États de l'Union européenne le
Royaume-Uni comme comme le les
États-Unis ont été capables d'appliquer
en un temps record des sanctions contre
un état autrement plus puissant les
paradis bancaires la Russie pourquoi ne
le fait-on pas sur ces paradis bancaires
ce serait à mon avis réduire à la source
les problèmes auxquels aujourd'hui la
France fait face en matière de
narcotrafic j'en ai terminé écoutez on a
beaucoup de et donc c'est notre
rapporteur Étienne blanc qui va
commencer les questions très bien merci
j'avais une question à Monsieur pugul
et la violence et vous l'expliquez par
le fait
que le trafic crée de la
dette les masses de drogue arrivent sur
un port français ensuite ils sont
éclatés vers des intermédiaires et puis
ensuite s diffusé vers des consommateurs
vers des dealers et cetera à l'échelon
plus faible à votre connaissance est-ce
qu'il y a des paiements en cash on nous
a dit tout à l'heure que c'était
peut-être possible avec le système des
bitcoins de dire je livre uniquement si
je suis payé et selon vous est-ce que ce
système d'endettement est vraiment à
l'origine de la violence notamment des
règlements de compte et des assassinats
que l'on connaît pour défaut de paiement
ou alors comme vous l'avez dit pour se
refaire et et et reconstituer un un un
réseau local moi j'aimerais vous nous
disiez selon vous quelle est la part du
paiement en cash et du paiement en
différé alors qui s'inscrit monsieur Pol
oui on parle pas des mêmes personnes en
fait puisque tout est segmenté puisqu'il
y a plus de pyramidal puisquil y a plus
de de de de chef de tout ça si je prends
la cocaïne il a les cartels mexicains
qui font qui font eux beaucoup d'argent
les les fameux 4000 % ok moi je parle
des gamins eux ils font rien ils font
des embrouilles des emmerdes pas
d'argent et des r M de compte la
violence pour ces jeunes qui sont des
milliers ceux qu'on appelle dealer quand
on les interpelle mais qui sont pas
dealer hein euh la violence pour ces
gamins c'est la seule compétence qu'ils
ait tout de suite exploitable être au
violent c'est le seul truc possible
faire peur à l'autre le zigouiller le
torturer parce que ils ont pas les les
contacts ils ont pas les réseaux ils ont
pas de matière à à à diffuser ce qui
veut dire que si je parle de d'argent
liquide ces jeunesl ils ne payent qu'en
argent liquide
uniquement les les les les les petits
qui vont acheter 10 kg par C 1 kg par ça
20 kg Cuxa c'est que de l'argent liquide
ensuite est-ce qu'il y a de l'argent
liquide entre le semi grossist celui de
la Castellane qui prend qui fait ses 500
kg semaine grosso modo et qui va acheter
au très gros qui a amené ça par
conttainur là oui aussi principalement
l'argent liquide on n pas trop dans des
dans des dans du paiement maintenant ils
ont mis en place les système de micro
paiement aussi alors à la base ce sont
des microopaiements qui sont faits par
téléphone pour un petit peu pour envoyer
des sous au bled ou pour c'est à la base
c'est c'est quelque chose de bien quoi
et c'est vrai qu'ils utilisent un petit
peu ça pour pour certains paiements mais
comme ils se font quand même avoir par
la police c'est pas non plus quelque
chose de de surutilisé chez les petits
j'ai envie de dire ceux qui s'entretu
ceux qui attirent l'attention ceux qui
sont dans les réseaux marseillais on est
principalement dans l'argent liquide par
contre les grossistes de ça eux quand
ils achètent au cartel quand ils
achètent au Maroc eux c'est des c'est
c'est en effet c'est de l'argent euh qui
va falloir blanchir donc il vaut mieux
que ça rentre des systèmes de de
cryptage et quant à la violence elle
elle est proportionnelle au niveau de de
de de faiblesse c'està-dire on utilise
des gros calibres la calach kckof quand
on est un petit calibre et les gros
réseaux de stup il y en a quelques-uns
je parlais de la Castellane et quelques
autres vous verrez il y a rarement des
règlements de compte et quand il y en a
ils sont fait au 9 mm c'est-à-dire ils
sont fait de façon efficace au gloc des
armes plus petites plus plus plus enfin
plus adapté à au meurtre en fait et donc
il faut réussir en fait à segmenter un
peu ces marchés là quand on veut les
combattre quand on veut combattre quand
on veut régler les problèmes dans les
cités c'est pas les cartels pas du tout
on n'est pas dans un système de cartel
donc en effet il y a plein de niveaux il
y a la diplomatie il y a il y a un
travail comme je disais sur vulnérable
un travail de police qui est plutôt
effectué mais qui a atteint ses limites
on pourrait avoir plus au moyens un
travail de PJ c'est encore autre chose
qui lui aussi est plutôt effectué 50 %
des règlements de comptes sont résolus à
Marseille alors son 30 % à l'échelle
français donc ça bosse mais pour autant
ça ralentit pas le le problème ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut pas le faire ça veut
dire que c'est pas la solution unique
donc en effet faut aller sur du social
évidemment pour les jeunes et il faut
aller ensuite sur la sction financière
pour les pour les réseaux avec les
paradis fiscaux et
compagnies alors selon vous aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui fait défaut à la France
pour lutter efficacement contre ce
narcotrafic un manque de moyens des
déficience juridique réglementaire une
absence de de volonté de priorité euh
non made vous quel est aujourd'hui le
point
faible si je peux comen vouz je continue
ou je je fais court euh pour moi il y a
il y a il y a pas de de de manque
juridique lourd sauf si on parle de
dépénalisation moi je vous l'ai dit je
suis favorable petit à petit et je suis
sûr que la dépénalisation règlera pas
tout je le sais j'en suis persuadé mais
la décriminalisation une certaine
dépénalisation va permettre de de de
travailler notamment sur les
consommateurs et c'est quand même le de
la guerre hein parce que s'il y a moins
de s'il y a moins de demande il y aura
l'offre se rencontrera un peu de vide je
ne crois pas moi
que toute une population peut basculer
sur une autre drogue les drogues elles
sont elles ont une fonction et le
fantanil en France pour le moment ça
prend pas le crack à Marseille ne prend
pas du tout pas du tout c'est 40
personnes qui prennent du crack parce
que c'est pas la drogue dont ils ont
besoin alors je sais pas dans 10 ans ou
dans 20 ans j' n'i aucune idée mais
aujourd'hui c'est pas ça donc il faut
travailler toujours pareil de façon plus
sociale plus plus sur les population
vulnérable en premier au niveau policier
on a fait des progrès depuis 2015 assez
considérabl hein c'est c'est ça a été
amené en 2012 par par hos le Premier
ministre de l'époque qui a qui a
vraiment accéléré les choses et ça s'est
senti évidemment il manque toujours des
moyens mais c'est pas le problème
principal aujourd'hui problème principal
à grande échelle et ça je suis pas
compétent c'est de la diplomatie on est
d'accord mais à petite échelle c'est du
social très clairement c'est c'est du
social moins d'en rue moins de
rénovation urbaine plus de travail sur
les
gens monsieur mon
pe dire juste un tout petit truc parce
que effectivement dans 5 minutes je dois
vous quitter
euh juste une toute petite toute petite
histoire c'est celle du du trafic de de
cocaïne
euh en provenance de la guillane
française vers le territoire hexagonal
euh juste un élément un pourquoi est-ce
qu'à un moment donné les les la pression
C exerci sur l'aéroport de Cayenne euh
alors que jusqu'à présent c'était pas le
cas c'est très simple en fait et qu'à un
moment donné euh au au départ longtemps
cette cette cocaïne a était acheminée à
partir du du Surinam vers euh l'aéroport
d'Amsterdam pendant très longtemps ça a
été la ligne la ligne officielle on va
dire de la de la cocaïne de cette
cocaïne là en tout cas qui est arrivé du
Surinam sachant que le Surinam est donc
un pays un narco-état qui a une
frontière avec la France et qui est à
proximité de la Colombie où euh les
barons de la drogue colombien ont tous
une ville là enfin c'est voilà on a on a
donc quasiment un bout de Colombie qui
touche le territoire français il faut il
faut faut jamais l'oublier d'une part et
d'autre part deux îles ou trois enfin
les Antilles françaises à mi-chemin pas
à mi-chemin mais à proximité de de de de
bateau à moteur de de la Colombie il
suffit d'aller là-bas une fois et de
s'en rendre compte vous allez sur une
plage et les gars la France l'Europe
c'est là c'est-à-dire qu'en gros
l'Europe est à portée de de bateaux avec
de bons moteurs des côtes du Venezuela
ou ou de la Colombie extrêmement
facilement et à partir du moment où vous
êtes euh en Guadeloupe ou en Martinique
le rebond est relativement simple en
utilisant toutes les failles les pororts
et cetera mais juste vous dire qu'est-ce
qui a fait qu'à un moment donné ça va
basculer vers l'aéroport de Cayenne
c'est extrêmement simple quand vous
regardez c'est juste que les les
Hollandais on ont fait très fort en
terme de communication je sais pas si ça
fonctionnait vraiment très très bien
derrière mais ils ont expliqué au
trafiquants qu'ils installaient à
l'aéroport de chipol des super scanners
qui allaient permettre de détecter en
gros tous ceux qui transporte transpor
de la cocaïne incorporée et qu'on
passerait on passerait tous les voilà
tous les passagers dans ces scanners
qu'on les détecterait alors ils l'ont
fait ils l'ont fait en vrai ils ont donc
acheté des scanners ils ont équipé
l'aéroport de scanner qui n'existe
toujours pas côté français et c'est
c'est c'est c'est aussi c'est aussi bien
la communication qui a été faite autour
de ces scanner que leur implantation
réelle qui a dévié le trafic et après
ils sont rendu compte que c'était très
simple vous savez il y a il y a un
fleuve à traverser hein le le Maroni
entre le Surinam et la France et la et
et la Guyane euh moi j'y suis allé là
pour le pour le dernier documentaire et
c'est vraiment frappant il y a une
vedette de de police française qui
patrouille régulièrement sur le le
fleuve à partir du moment où elle sort
parce qu'elle peut pas sortir tout le
temps à partir du moment où elle sort
vous avez des des sonnettes qui
s'activent un petit peu partout et plus
personne ne bouge sur le fleuve en tout
cas plus personne ne transportant des
produits illégaux ne bouge sur le fleuve
c'est là là vous vous rendez compte
quand vous êtes face à face à ce à à ce
fleuve de l'immensité de la difficulté
du problème c'est qu'il y a des
centaines de piroges qui passent toute
la journée et que en face il y a qu'une
barque qui paraît qu'il y en aura une
deuxième bientôt mais il a fallu quand
même 4 5 ans à l'état français pour
réagir aujourd'hui le problème est pas
résolu complètement on n pas encore ces
fameux scanners mais mais globalement le
problème a été résolu en mettant un
filet de sécurité extrêmement sévère au
départ de Cayen et quiconque essae
aujourd'hui de d'embarquer le le le
verrain assez facilement il a il y a
vraiment une barrière qui a été dressée
mais je suis prêt à parier je suis prêt
à parier parce que je voilà j'ai des
informations de ce côté-là que en fait
ça va être assez ils vont ils vont
rapidement trouver le moyen de
contourner cette barrière et comment bah
par la corruption dont on a déjà parlé
plusieurs d'entre nous ont déjà parlé il
suffit de corrompre quelques policiers
quelques douaniers quelques dockur
quelques personnel des quelques
personnels naviguant et de passer cette
première barrière très apparente c'est
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
c'est-à-dire en gros d'introduire le
produit au-delà de cette première
barrière de la contourner ça va être
relativement simple tout ça pour vous
dire voilà l'élément essentiel de ce que
je voulais vous dire c'est que
l'installation à un moment donné la
communication est extrêmement importante
vis-à-vis des trafiquants et et aussi la
technique et les investissements parce
que c scan C scanner coûte cher et pose
un certain nombre de problèmes liés au
droits de l'homme qui font que en France
on a parce que bon c'est une fouille un
scanner incorporée ça permet y a il y a
eu des des barrières qui on qui ont
empêché cette implantation et qui ont
retardé le contrôle voilà moi je je
voulais je voulais vous remercier pour
l'invitation et je suis désolé je suis
obligé de de partir un
rendez-vous merci de votre contribution
merci pour votre écoute et je serais
heureux de vous lire monsieur Monet
oui très
rapidement encore une fois pour pour
passer pas mal de temps avec des des
trafiquants ils ne font ça que pour
l'argent voilà donc la façon d'être
efficace c'est de diminuer leur
motivation et donc de compliquer leur
possibilité de de gagner de
l'argent pour ça je pense que et ça
répond aussi à une des questions que
vous
posiez la saisie des avoirs je sais que
vous avez auditionné l'autorité en
France mais à mon avis c'est vraiment
l'exemple italien était remarquable bon
c'est une chose mais c'est aussi limité
il y a des trous dans les dispositifs
antiblanchiment qui à mon avis il serait
très très simple de combler on a parlé
des cryptos soyons précis comment est-ce
que un quelqu'un qui vend même 10 kg de
cocaïne peut-il utiliser des cryptos les
cryptonnaaies ça ça s'achète
généralement sur des plateformes en
ligne mais ça s'achète aussi en cash
soit on peut les acheter directement en
cash c'est malheureusement parfaitement
légal c'est sans aucune limite il y a
pas de loi qui limite le montant
possible de de d'achat en cash de crypto
premièrement et deuxièmement il y a des
outils qui sont extrêmement faciles
parfaitement lgau vous pouvez en acheter
à 300 m d'ici dans les bureaux de tabac
vous pouvez acheter des cartes prépayées
avec du cash on ne vous demandera rien
sinon une pièce d'identité et le
buraliste qui vous la vend n'est pas
fondé à vérifier l'authenticité de la
pièce d'identité euh et avec ça vous
allez acheter une carte transcche ou
autre je veux pas in criminer de société
mais euh évidemment c'est pas une
personne qui en achète c'est 3000 vous
transformez euh votre chiffre d'affaires
de la vente de coque en carte prépayée
avec lesqueles vous alleer sur des
plateformes parfaitement légales qui
vous permettent d'acheter autant de
cryptoonnaiees que vous voulez euh et je
pense qu'il n'est pas très compliqué de
limiter ou en tout cas de de de de
contingenter les possibilités d'achat de
ces ces ces ces cartes par exemple en
obligeant à ce que ces ces cartes ne
soient achetées que dans des organismes
comme la poste ou autrees et pas voilà
donc c'est des choses à mon avis très
simples qui peuvent pour revenir à ce
que disait monsieur ce que disait
monsieur Ploquin faire comprendre à ces
gens que c'est plus aussi facile
qu'avant voilà et lutter saisir les
avoirs c'est une chose compliquer le
blanchiment c'est tellement facile
aujourd'hui de blanchir ça va forcément
faire disparaître certaines
vocations merci je crois qu'il y a
quelques questions mariearlette Carlotti
oui merci à tous parce que vraiment
c'était très intéressant et vous nous
faites mesurer l'ampleur de notre tâche
c'est extrêmement inquiétant alors moi
je suis très sensible à ce que tu as dit
à ce qu'a dit Philippe Pujol parce que
tous les quartiers de Marseille dont il
parle ça me parle je les connais mais du
coup il a fait tomber en moi une espèce
de fantasme il disait l'argent facile à
Marseille oui moi je pensais que les
petits des quartiers les minau qui
revendent qu'on appelle dealer ou que
justement vous venez d'appeler les
vulnérables et ben je croyais qu'au
moins il gagnit un peu d'argent quoi
voilà donc vous êtes en train de
m'expliquer que ils sont surendettés
qu'ils sont dans un système qui sont
même pris au piège définitivement et je
trouve ça très intéressant moi j'ai très
bien compris depuis le début que chasser
les points de Deal bah c'était
nécessaire mais ça faisait un peu de de
l'image ça faisait de l'extérieur mais
ça servait au fond à rien et là vous
expliquez que désormais il va falloir
aller plus loin s'occuper des
vulnérables s'occuper vous avez un peu
répondu à la question que je voulais
vous poser s'occuper des questions
sociales ça veut dire avoir aussi
au-delà des services publics qui ont
quitté ses quartiers et cetera mais
avoir aussi des mesures d'accompagnement
et dans notre rapport peut-être
faudra-t-il aussi qu'on évoque comment
les sortir de là un jour il y a
quelqu'un qui est venu témoigner ici et
qui a dit finalement il faut leur dire
qu'il rentent dans des réseaux moi moi à
l'intérieur de moi je me suis dit mais
non ce qui est important pour eux c'est
finalement d'avoir une assise sociale
d'exister dans la société vous êtes en
train de faire tomber tout ce que je
croyais de ce point de vue vue donc
voilà expliquez-moi mieux et comment on
peut davantage les accompagner au-delà
de d'avoir des écoles des services
publics qui fonctionnent et des hôpitaux
et cetera et la deuxième question elle
est pour Monsieur Mony là moi je j'ai
j'ai bien compris comment comment ça
pouvait se structurer vous avez expliqué
le système pyramidal les coopératives
selon les endroits comment ça se plaque
en France ça parce que je sais pas
comment on se structure au niveau là
j'ai parlé du plus bas de du deal
maintenant je parle d'en haut comment ça
comment vous plaquez ça en France je
prends l'exemple de la Corse où il y a
eu des choses complètement qui n'étaient
pas très pyramidales voyez le petit bar
en cor du Sud où où la brise c'était des
copains qui fréquenter le bistro les
enfants ont voulu je sais pas comment on
arrive à monter le système français
comment il comment il se il se
décortique ce système français par
rapport à ce que vous avez vécu un peu
partout non non mais il fallait
développer l'idée et est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres questions moi j'en rajouterai
une peut-être sur
euh
moi je suis entré dans dans cette
commission d'enquête avec l'idée qu'il
avait la pas du gain et puis on découvre
que la criminalité forcée elle est à
tous les étages ce qui nous a été dit
sur sur Marseille mais c'est ce qui est
dit par rapport à certaines formes de
corruption on parle des doers on voit
que c'est pas
forcément pour gagner beaucoup d'argent
c'est des fois pour se protéger et
protéger sa famille est-ce que vous
pouvez làdessus donner quelques
éclairages et je crois que
question
oui vous avez
fait vous avez parlé d'une
expérience que vous avez partagé sur le
blanchiment à Dubaï la problématique
quand on Sete aux questions de
blanchiment c'est que on Sete en fait à
la au carrefour de tous les trafics
parce que beaucoup cherchent à blanchir
pour contourner les sanctions
économiques puisque vous parliez à un
moment de la Russie pour la Russie pour
tourner les sanctions économiques
utilise aussi ces ces réseaux et toute
notre difficulté effectivement c'est de
d'essayer de de regarder comment tout ça
fonctionne donc dès qu'on rentre sur la
question du blanchiment on on se
confronte à la au au financement du
terrorisme c'est on retrouve tout ça en
fait tous ces circuits euh vous n'avez
pas mentionné le Venezuela qui justement
est aussi un je dirais une sorte de
d'autoroute entre la Colombie et ce
qu'on a vu encore tout à l'heure les
Antilles et qui
justement aussi aide beaucoup à je
dirais blanchir l'argent c'est pour
financer simplement l'état un état qui
était sous sanction donc comment euh
cont tenu de parce que on parle des des
plateformes on parle de Dubaï mais je
crois que c'est notre c'est Christophe
perueux qui avait qui a dit que il n'y a
plus du tout de réponse de la part de
Hong Kong cela bloque complètement
toutes les enquêtes donc nous en fait on
est en train de se rendre compte que que
euh dans ce domaine en réalité
effectivement on sorte aujourd'hui un
mur puisqueil y a des gens des nations
qui ont intérêt et finalement qui ont un
intérêt convergent avec cette industrie
de la drogue
non alors dernière série de réponses
monsieur Monet oui alors madame
peut-être que Monsieur Pujol répondra de
façon plus autorisée que moi sur la
façon dont c'est ce type de structure
existe en France je ne travaille pas en
France donc je malheureusement je je ne
connais pas euh pour revenir donc je
vous prie de m'excuser pour ça mais je
vraiment je je suis pas autorisé à le
faire euh pour venir à votre point sur
la oui la la l'implication forcée
finalement que décrivait monsieur Pujol
pour les les trafiquants eux-mêmes enfin
les c'est C ces jeunes ont porté euh je
pense qu'effectivement il y a une partie
des autorités corrompues qui n'ont tout
simplement pas le choix et c'est le la
bonne vieille retournel Plata au plomo
quand on est à couiaacan la capitale du
car Hel de Sinaloa qu'on vousit dans
certains quartiers de saan Paulo ou à
Manaos qui est l'épicentre du trafic au
cœur de l'Amazonie les policiers font la
circulation pour laisser passer les
narcos ils sont payés par eux mais
est-ce qu'on peut les incriminer je ne
le pense pas parce que c'est soit
collaborer gagner de l'argent pas
énormément d'ailleurs soit prendre une
balle dans la tête et et ce qui s'est
produit au avavre encore une fois je
n'excuse pas mais j'explique hein donc
voilà éloignons-nous évidemment des des
des des considérations à l'emportepèce
mais voilà je pense que toute personne
confrontée à ce choix-là avant de penser
à l'argent il va d'abord penser à la vie
de son enfant parce que généralement
c'est les deux euh sur la question du
blanchiment monsieur le sénateur je
pense que effectivement tout est là
alors je n'ai pas travaillé au Venezuela
donc je je je ne je ne connais pas tout
est là
et c'est impossible de quantifier la
proportion dans les flux d'argent euh
placés dans des paradis bancaire ça a
été très très bien évalué he par des
chercheurs namment chercheurs français
l'Université de Colombia euh
on sait que c'est à peu près entre 5 et
7 % du PIB mondial voilà ce que ça
représente 5 à 7 % du PIB mondial c'est
très très très très aessus du chiffre
d'affaires criminel ça veut dire qu'en
fait dans ces paradis bancaires qui
trouve-t-on sans doute des organisations
criminelles à l'évidence j'ai pu
l'observer mais pour beaucoup des
entités qui sont parfaitement légales on
va du fraudeur fiscal pardon qui ne sont
pas des des organisations criminelles on
va il y a des entités illégales qui sont
les fraudeurs fiscaux c'est une chose
mais il a aussi des entreprises et je
vous renvoie la lecture d'un d'un d'un
livre absolument magistral fondé sur sur
l'expérience une expérience extensive de
du juge Renau van runbeck qui a passé
son des années à essayer de de de casser
ces réseaux là qui s'est heurté à ce mur
que vous évoquez des entreprises qui
sont parfaitement légales et qui font
dans ces pays ce qu'elles appellent de
l'optimisation fiscale est-ce de est-ce
de l'évasion fiscale en droit non c'est
de l'optimisation fiscale mais la seule
justification à à à à l'existence encore
aujourd'hui de ces trous noirs c'est
quoi c'est que que tous les États
notamment la zone OCDE on parle pas de
la Chine savent très bien que dans ces
paradis bancaires on trouve des orations
criminelles contre lesqueles elles
lutent mais que ces paradis bancaires
sont aussi surtout en temps de crise
absolument nécessaires à des entreprises
qui leur propres entreprises qui
finalement sont drogué à une forme
d'vison fiscale qui est tolérée qu'on
appelle optimisation fiscale mais un
magistrat il va pas appeler ça
optimisation fiscale je pense vous en
avez auditionn plusieurs qui ont dû vous
dire cela donc en fait tout est là c'est
une forme d'hypocrisie fondamentale à
mon sens
à telle enseigne qu'il existe un paradis
bancaire sur le territoire américain
l'état du delower hein donc et combien
de paradis bancaires entoure la France
et voir c'est un il y a pas de
définition du Paradis bancaire mais
combien d'états ne sont-ils sont-ils si
peu coopératifs y compris des états
européen he donc tout est là c'est cette
forme d'hypocrisie tant qu'on a pas
résolu ce problème fondamental voilà
pour ce qui est de Hong Kong l'entretien
auquel j'ai assisté les les ingénieurs
en blanchiment d'argent qui conseillai
le narco etc qui j'étais ont tout de
suite mentionné ça et ont dit on va
passer par Hong Kong parce que Hong Kong
c'est la Chine et Hong Kong maintenant
depuis que l'État chinois est vraiment
extrêmement présent ne coopère
absolument plus c'est le le trou noir du
trou noir avec Dubaï il y a un autre
pays je terminerai là-dessus qui en
train vraiment de de devenir une forme
de paradis bancaire à l'heure où on
parle deélergissement européen c'est le
montenégro hein qui est bien connu de
beaucoup de narcotrafiquants pour la
permissivité de son système bancaire euh
et là aussi le nombre de réponse aux
demandes de coopération judiciaire à mon
avis est extrêmement faible donc encore
un nouveau paradis qui est né mais voilà
je rejoins votre votre point c'est un
mur d'opacité qu'on ne pourra à mon sens
faire tomber que par une pression l'État
français pour ça je pense doit être cité
en exemple he le ministre de l'Intérieur
s'est déplacé il y a quelques semaines à
Dubaï ça n'a pas plu mais il est allé
porter la voix des autorités judicière
française si chaque État européen
faisait cet effort là peut-être
peut-être qu'on arriverait à convaincre
il y a une autre question je terminerai
là-dessus sur sur Dubaï et sur d'autres
paradis bancaires c'est le rôle
géopolitique qu'ils ont aujourd'hui
notamment en Moyen-Orient qui fait que
contraindre Dubaï aujourd'hui c'est sans
doute se priver d'une voie diplomatique
peut-être utile par ailleurs donc là il
s'agit de pragmatisme et non pas
d'aveuglement mais toujours est-il que
oui ce mur en tout cas on n pas encore
trouvé la solution pour le faire
tomber monsieur molignier au Pujol
oui non simplement peut-être une une
remarque parce qu'on parle de quelles
sont les les les solutions
euh dans la lutte contre le les les
trafics de stupéfiants euh en fait la
question aussi il faut que s'interroger
je pense sur euh quel est le but de
guerre en fait pour reprendre un terme
euh un terme euh militaire c'est-à-dire
que vous avez je crois 60 tonnes enfin
en tout cas c'est les projections vous
avez 60 tonnes de cannabis qui rentent
sur le territoire français chaque mois
euh dans les meilleurs mois on est à 10
10 tonnes de cannabis saisi euh on est à
10 % euh voilà du du SI euh je suis nul
en math mais voilà ça c'est quand même
une une proportion assez assez faible et
surtout il y a pas de
rupture de il y a pas de rupture dans la
chaîne d'approvisionnement c'estàdire
queil y a il y a aucun consommateur qui
vous dit que il a du mal à à se procurer
son produit donc la question voilà c'est
vrai que souvent enfin moi moi
j'aimerais j'aimerais comprendre quel
est le quelle est la la parole publique
là-dessus quel est le but de guerre quel
est le but de de la lutte du trafic de
stupéfiants est-ce que c'est de contenir
cette évolution est-ce que c'est de
l'accompagner ou est-ce que c'est de la
reférainer et de la refaire tomber et
tous les moyens qui vont être mis en
place derrière doivent être à mon sens
pris à la lumière de ce de cette réponse
à cette
question merci Monsieur Pujol vous Z le
dernier mot oui sur la sur l'approche
sociale sur questionapoche sociale c'est
dans la continuité de ce qui vient
d'être dit d'ailleurs euh si on si on
fait fait un zoom un zoom arrière on
part on part du du du départ
c'est-à-dire les consommateurs s'il y a
de la drogue s'il y a des gens qui qui
en prennent comme le disais il y a
principalement des consommateurs pour
des raisons peu de festif le festif
c'est peut-être ce qui se voit le plus
parce que on est peut-être amené à en
croiser à connaître ça mais en fait la
masse de la consommation n'est pas une
consommation festive pas du tout et donc
déjà il y a un travail à faire sur les
consommation et le travail à faire sur
la consommation ne se fais ne se fera
que dans un cadre légal et vous avez des
des addct qui vont dire qu'il faut un
cadre légal tout simplement on est la
médecine du travail quelqu'un on va lui
demander alors l'alcool il va dire ah
oui j'abuse un petit peu c'est vrai si
on va lui dire la cocaïne moi'y touche
pas alors que si dans un casre légal il
pourra dire c'est vrai j'abuse un petit
peu et là on pourra rentrer dans système
de soin déjà il y a quel chose à faire
sur le consommateurite on parlait de
l'proche sociale àortter sur les
vulnérablesppeil prenant rapidement
quelques cas je disais a les mineurs les
mineurs accompagn les MNA bah
aujourd'hui particulièrement à Marseille
et probablement ailleurs c'est pas la
population la plus accompagnée
finalement donc c'est une population
vulnérable qui au-delà des des
considérations morales et idéologiques
est une matière une une matière idéale
pour pour des petits dealers qui vont
avoir besoin de plus faible queeux pour
travailler gratuitement de la même
manière les foyers qui sont des les
foyers de de de jeunes hein de jeunes un
problème on va dire et des mesures AEMO
c'est c'est sont des des des foyers qui
sont saturés aujourd'hui ils ont été
saturés à partir ils ont toujours été
assez pleins mais on les a saturé au
moment où il y a eu le confinement parce
que les jeunes se retrouvant à la maison
bah il y en a qui ont pris des roustes
qui se sont fait taper dessus et donc on
a pris ces jeunes et on les a mis en
foyer pour les protéger sauf que ça a
rempli les foyers de jeunes qui bon
étaient pas dans des problématiques de
drogue de de on les a mis pour les
protéger on les a mis dans des endroit
où au contraire on va les recruter on va
aller les chercher et donc ça c'est
c'est peut-être qu'il faudra un petit
peu revoir la manière de de de de faire
du social avec des les différents
profils et ensuite euh pour pour pour
les les les jeunes vulnérables de chaque
il y a des cas différents hein mais de
de de citer ben il faut cibler enfin les
merceul les enfants vont tomber dedans à
coup sûr les grandes frateries les
enfants vont tomber dedans un truc tout
bête un enfant qui n'a pas sa clé pour
rentrer chez lui en sortant du collège
qui va attendre en bas en jouant en
jouant dans la cour il est foutu il va
se faire attraper d'abord face sont
sympa on va le faire rêver et ensuite on
va la on va l'attraper il suffirait tout
simplement qu'il y ait un lieu pour ces
jeunes en Allemagne ils appellent ça les
enfants clés faudrait qu'il y ait un
lieu où ils attendent où ils vont
quelque part donc avant c'était les
centres sociaux mais les centres sociaux
il y en a moins et ils sont moins
attractifs pour plein de raison donc
voilà il y a il y a évidemment toute une
série de solutions et si on continue à
remonter euh si moi je m'arrête jusqu'à
la barrière euh qui est la douane
aujourd'hui la douane à Marseille moi je
suis fils de douanier père et mère j'ai
grandi à caserne des douanes aujourd'hui
la casern des doines il y a plus de
doigners et sur le port il y a cinq
doiniers pour Port Saint-Louis du Ron
c'est monumental donc on peut avoir un
scanner mais le scanner qui va scanner
un containur si c'est un containur de
charbon de bois la densité du charbon
est exactement identique à la densité du
cheat ou de ou de ou de la cocaïne donc
ça ne sert à rien là si on doit avoir
des moyens les moyens douaniers doivent
être remis massivement et
particulièrement de douanes judiciair
c'est-à-dire d'enquête et euh et à la
question quel est le modèle français euh
ben en fait la mafia moi pour moi il y a
pas de mafia en France parce qu'on a
quelque chose d'un peu plus un peu plus
français je dirais la mafia c'est quand
le banditisme va corrompre je faire en
version courte va corrompre et va tenir
d'une main ferme des politiques des des
des des des magistrats même s'il le faut
enfin en tout cas ils vont corrompre
énormément en France on a quelque chose
de plus sournois qui s'appelle le
clientélisme c'est-à-dire que jamais un
élu à Marseille va se maquer avec un
trafiquant de drogue directement ça
n'arrivera pas déjà ils ont pas ce
cynisme là et en
plus c'est c'est c'est c'est plus
subtile finalement ça se fait sur du
clientélisme c'est-àdire les trafiquants
de drogue vont avoir des assauts qui
vont avoir ils vont avoir des
entreprises ils vont avoir différentes
choses qui vont travailler indirectement
pour l'élu mais surtout ils vont
travailler d'un point de vue électoral
ils vont pas travailler directement avec
des échanges d'argent les échanges
d'argent ils se font presque légalement
sur un marché sur et ensuite sur des
aides aux élections ça peut paraître
dérisoire et rigolo on en fait des
galjades mais en fait comme c'est
permanent bah ça devient quelque chose
qui est plus puissant ou au moins aussi
puissant que le banditisme ça nécessite
pas de violence pour eux il y a pas de
violence et si on prend un juge
antiorruption ça a été le cas on a pris
le juge du chîn c'est une sorte de juge
antiorruption qui est resté quelques
années à Marseille mais tu repars
bredouille parce qu' de la corruption il
en a très peu donc euh le clientélisme
ça se ça ça se combat plutôt avec les
services d'inspection des des
des les inspections des services
inspections administrativ les les les
enfin voilà toutes ces chambres là c'est
pas très sexy c'est pas marrant c'est
pas très euh c'est c'est c'est pas très
médiatique mais c'est finalement des des
des des des des choses qui ont été
totalement affaiblies ces dernières
années et si on veut combattre pour le
système français qui est pas que
marseillais c'est juste que à Marseille
c'est un peu plus fort et surtout plus
visible mais euh il faut faut combattre
le clientélisme avant tout en tout cas
certains clientélisme parce que là aussi
le clientélisme on en viendra pas à
vousout mais certains clientélisme donc
euh donc oui il y a plein de il y a
plein de d'orientation à prendre c'est
un problématique m multisectorielle
c'est
certain merci
euh sauf à ce que vous ayez des choses à
rajouter à ce stade je vois pas de
demande d'intervention chez mes
collègues donc on va vous remercier très
chaleureusement de votre participation à
cette commission d'enquête et on va se
plonger dans vos écrits dans vos
documentaires pour approfondir tout ce
que vous nous avez dit merci beaucoup
Monsieur Merci
beaucoup